joining me now steve forbes chairman and
editor-in-chief of forbes media and
former republican presidential candidate
great to see you today
so that seems significant though so
nancy pelosi in the
last few minutes says dims are willing
now to take their offer down
from 3 trillion to 2 trillion
the white house wouldn't come to that at
least not yet what do you make of it
i don't think it's the numbers per se
whether it's 1 2 or 3 trillion what
really matters is what's in that package
and i think the biggest thing the
president could do to stimulate the
economy going into the third and fourth
quarters third quarter now going into
the fourth quarter
is suspending the payroll tax if you're
making 40 000
a year that's the equivalent of three
thousand dollars extra pay
tax free if you're an employer that
means of hiring somebody at forty
thousand
that cost suddenly goes down three
thousand dollars he suspends that
payroll tax
for a period of time eight months twelve
months that would be a very very
powerful
stimulant the real nubbin of the thing i
think is what they do on unemployment
benefits
and right now i think what they should
be pushing for the republicans instead
of negotiating on that
instead go for a big individual
check for individuals we did twelve
hundred dollars per individual in the
spring
they should go for fifteen hundred or
two thousand dollars going into the fall
that would take care of anything that
happens on the unemployment benefits
give people money instantly and lowering
the
payroll tax lowering the cost of hiring
people that preserves jobs creates jobs
those two things big individual checks
suspending the payroll tax
that would really boost the economy
you know what's fascinating about your
saying at least to me is look i
there are a lot of smaller government
people out there i i don't think you
want to see the government get
bigger with more deficit but what you're
saying is you got to meet this moment
with something big that's what i hear
from you
look i want to get your take on the
unemployment rate which fell below
expectations last month down a third
straight month
from a high of 14.7 percent in april
and as for the jobs added as we said 1.8
million
in july down from nearly 4.8 million
added
the month before but not nearly as close
to the
21 million lost in april what do you
make of all of it steve
well healing an economy that took such a
savage hit as it did in the
march and april i think that this is
good progress especially in light
of the burst that we had in corona virus
cases in the south and southwest
and so we're adding 1.8 million you
continue that
in september october you're going to get
the unemployment rate down to single
digits if anyone in the spring had said
we'd go from what people
thought would be 20 25 unemployment down
to 8 percent which is about where it was
when barack obama ran for reelection
people would have said that's phenomenal
can't happen but it is happening
and we do the right thing on the payroll
tax and those individual checks
you could as you see that rate do even
better businesses are uncertain
and i don't think you're going to get
the real rocket for free to the economy
till people know what's going to happen
in january are we going to have a high
tax regime high regulation regime
or low tax regime and the low regulation
regime
that's fundamental you couldn't have a
stroke of choice in november about what
course
economic course the country's going to
take
all right and also obviously a vaccine
or some even more vastly
effective therapeutics i want to get to
this um
you know a pro-trump super pac says it
won't be silenced by the woke
elite after facebook has banned its
advertising
the head of the group um is saying the
committee
will not be silenced by woke silicon
valley elites as we expose the real joe
biden
um and and part of the problem here we
have real cal
reallocated our entire facebook budget
to other online platforms so americans
can see the whole truth not just
facebook's truth
so steve part of the problem here is
that facebook has put itself into what i
thought zukerberg said they weren't
going to do and that's fact-checking
business
do they have a fiduciary responsibility
to do that
or is this stomping on free speech
well facebook and these other high-tech
giants and i thought facebook until now
was doing the right thing saying unless
it's
illegal or egregiously offensive uh they
weren't going to
try to police each and every piece that
goes online was the right thing to do
but doing what they just did now just
stokes the anti-high-tech
attitude that you get both on the left
and the right needlessly making enemies
uh conservatives and libertarians would
be the natural allies of companies like
facebook
but they egregiously kick them in the
shins of facebook and others
cool especially kick him in the shins
unnecessarily
so that was a mistake on facebook's part
they should continue to say
unless it's egregiously wrong we're
going to let things run and let the
public judge whether you like or not
likes a
political particular political ad
yeah so they they cherry pictures you
say this pro-trump
super pac uh from advertising on the
platform and they ask for
trouble they're just gonna dig
themselves in deeper unnecessarily all
right steve forbes i can't wait for you
to come back on the program thank you